mimes for scum people call me for his
gun Tom Hanks gave the performance of a
lifetime in Forrest Gump and only et
knows how all those unforgettable
on-screen moments came to be stupid is
as stupid does
[Music]
my mom always said life was like a box
of chocolates
you never know what you're going to get
the bus stop shot was one spot for many
many days Savannah yeah we were in
Savannah Georgia yeah the better part if
I think four days of shooting I didn't
know him for that yeah all the
sacrifices when I know it for your craft
honestly goes back to what mama said
this whole view of the cosmos and our
consciousness was really dictated by the
way mama explained the world to him you
know and and she did it in in kind of
unconventional kind of ways you know she
says to him you know differ from anybody
else and if God wanted everybody to be
the same you giving us all braces on our
legs you know that kind of logic is it
ends up being the the whole
superstructure for the way forrest gump
relates to everything what purpose in
this army to do whatever you tell my
drill sergeant it's some great special
effects in this film like the explosion
scene in Vietnam can you tell us that
the Vietnam stuff was very very
particular because when it wasn't the
whole movie I mean it's not the
absolutely everything but it was it's we
could not show it and not have it be as
authentic as we possibly could make it
what we wanted it to be was frightening
but we wanted it to be that kind of
thing I must say that when we were done
shooting that which was loud and hairy
even for us Micheal T Williams son and
Gary Sinise and I kind of looked at each
other and we thought if it's that scary
for us now and we're just pretending
what in the world did did these men go
through when they were there
congratulations how do you be how about
the archival stuff getting in the scene
with Nixon and getting into a scene with
Johnson and well those were really all
very complex stuff that we shot because
we built all those sets and we cast all
those parts and so we actually shot all
of that stuff like a regular movie with
regular movie cameras but then there are
these moments in it where I did go off
and shoot blue-screen stuff in which I'm
reacting to a piece of tape for a couple
of moments and they did some sort of
marriage
between footage that actually existed
that was then we pixellated some of this
stuff is absolute state-of-the-art
computer-generated special effects but
in this case I don't know how I ended up
standing there getting having Lyndon
Johnson with his arms around me but you
know there it is yes it's it's pretty
it's an amazing thing did you go to all
those sites and do the running and we
went to a lot of them yeah there was a
second unit that went off to places like
Montana and Utah we went to I think that
the official tally was 11 states and two
nations the Navajo Nation was was oh it
was one of them we were we were there
but yeah we a lot of weekends we just
kind of congregated at the airport and
we flew to Maine and shot and New
Hampshire and Vermont and North Carolina
we were all over the place I never
thanked you for saving my life
after all of this incredible epic Road
that forest goes down he kind of comes
to the conclusion which is the one that
Bob told us at the very very beginning
of shooting that our destiny is to
wander around and try to figure stuff
out that's what our destiny is it's
almost like a Zen kind of outlook on
life but forest stumbles upon it like
very early on because Jenny his
girlfriend in college says who do you
want to be forests and forest says well
aren't aren't I going to be me and is
that that's the outlook that he has that
there's no altering everything anything
that goes on there's only the accepting
of everything goes on which you know has
probably an idea that has had more pages
devoted to it in the history of mankind
than than the existence of God himself
so
about that
[Music]